vous êtes prête pour une interview nul à
la bouche un ring bien donc on va faire
un permis nul de toute façon est ce que
vous connaissez que thil de cours aux
côtés de kuro il ya une question
maintenant qui s'appelle la question
clotilde courau et je vous la pose mais
entendu est-ce que vous embrasse reliés
par amour cent fois une paire de
chaussettes sales de dany boon
non vous ne feriez pas où ça non non
vous n'êtes pas comme côté de pau non
est ce que vous préférez votre père ou
votre mère celle intervenue là je sais
ce que tu aimerais mieux rouler une
pelle et à mains au coucher avec ton
père d'améliorer la question est les
deux d'accord je suis un pas accepté les
2 1 est-ce que vous accorderez y ait
plus de circonstances atténuantes à un
vieux qui se tape des petites ou un
jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles mais
pourquoi faudrait-il que les
circonstances atténuantes
parce que un jeu qui se tape des petites
oui ça vous gêne pas à vous les jeunes
ou vieilles attend hors de question
qu'un jeune thème sur une vieille vous
préférez les vieux qui se tape des
oeuvres si elles sont consentantes
oui c'est vrai j'aurais pas dû vous
poser cette question est-ce que vous
préfériez faire l'amour avec un mec très
laid ou une fille très belle fille très
belle puis 13
est-ce que points est ce que pour voir
il ya un ami qui rentre chez vous la
nuit dans votre chambre ou un copain
n'eussent pas du tout est ce que vous
auriez plus honte qu'ils trouvent sur
votre table de chevet le livre de claire
chazal ou un godemiché un godemichet ça
vous ferait plus sombre que le livre de
classe mais enfin on passait
un sentiment qu'est ce que j'en ai à
[ __ ]
ni l'un ni l'autre enfin gea foot moi
quel est votre punition préféré être là
ces mordus ou pique et pince mardi à
mort du seul faisait médias que mordu
ouais on note tout est là tout est noté
tout est enregistré sur bande
est-ce que alors maintenant sérieusement
dany boon il est une pâte sexuelle est
une hypothèse évidemment n'est pas une
panne sexuelle
peut-être à besançon les enseignants
j'ai passé hypothèse alors lienemann
sexuelle un jour ça m'étonnerait avec
vous qu'on puisse avoir des pannes
sexuelles mais c'est un jeu vous lui
demander comment elle s'appelle première
solution vous lui faites un truc à vous
de trucs à vous ou vous casser en
claquant la porte
moi j'y fais un truc à moi promet
ensuite je lui demande comment elle
s'appelle et finalement je me rendors
bravo belle réponse
alors dit naji mais c'est plusieurs
auditions position vous disparaissez
dany aussi mais bon on attend dommage là
il disparaît s'il meurt c'est pas un
truc c'est inler s'est pas il me c'est
la partie un peu solennelle d'une ligne
oui ça fait partir un peu hard alors bon
vous mourrez tous les deux
est-ce que vous préféreriez que noël
soit confiée à julien courbet avait
l'audace élevé par julien courbet le
petit bataille et fontaine français
violent aussi un mini moto julien
courbet bataille et fontaine où
christophe dechavanne rendu à vannes 1 2
finale du cheval
si les tournées lycos a nui ce jour les
gosses ouais si vous deviez mourir dans
un crash d'avion et un rendez vous prévu
comme ça voilà sachant que des gosses
sont élevés par julien combe bien cadré
dernières paroles avant de décéder
vous mourrez dans un crâne d'ailleurs
est-ce que vous préféreriez un avion
d'air france d'egypte des roues de la
varité à celles intervenues mais
regardez pas que ce principe
qu'est-ce que vous avez passé d une part
terim un avion français
alors
beaucoup plus yann galy question est-ce
que vous préféreriez être incarné ans
marguerite duras ou marilyn monroe ou
julien courbet marguerite duras
ah bon c'est son côté intello ça mais
quand on est marilyn monroe on peut
encore apprendre mais quand on est durs
à son peut jamais devenir marié
maintenant quand même une certaine façon
elle a été mariée le mot no non là on
l'a pas vu ça nous a bien aimé la façon
de reconnaître que marilyn
personne n'a remarqué c'est incroyable
qu'elle montait de tester vous prononcez
à part courbe prononcée
ouais le mot qui vous n'arrivez pas à
prononcer quelques secondes sans pied à
s'il vous plaît pas ce nom vous dit
comment
avoir du plaisir